podría propagarse muy rápidamente según
el último aviso del consejo científico
la variante omicron circular a europa de
manera más fuerte a lo previsto y
amenaza con convertirse en la dominante
en francia al club inglés copei y el
último
johnson con la priori debería propagarse
un poco más lentamente en francia que en
reino unido porque estamos algo más
vacunados con la tercera dosis pero como
se propaga más fácilmente que la
variante delta es muy probable que en
las próximas semanas la sobrepase y
provoque un rebrote epidémico
delta y luego que algún límite una
dinámica que podría incrementar la
presión en los hospitales según el sitio
web kobe tracker las admisiones en
cuidados intensivos ya han aumentado un
27% en relación a la semana anterior
todos los días hay personas que llegan a
cuidados intensivos cada día el número
de personas que llegan en esta situación
es superior al día anterior y yo guapa
como las aguas de clarín yo no veo cómo
nos las vamos a arreglar con la llegada
de un micrón ante esta amenaza
científico pide evitar las grandes
reuniones por las fiestas de navidad que
podrían acelerar los contagios